Heidelberg in southwest Germany is a
famous tourist destination it has a
beautiful old town and a ruined castle
on the hill but it also has a modern
side a three thousand unit residential
complex built to passive house standards
is going up on the site of an old goods
yard pet repair scene and her family
were among the first to move in two
years ago people and appliances give off
so much heat but hardly any additional
heating is needed in a badly built house
or if you have single glazed windows or
patio door they'll always be a draft
around your feet or you feel it in your
neck and back and the floor will be cold
your feet feel the cold first that just
doesn't happen in a passive house once
you've got used to it you can't imagine
living anywhere that's poorly insulated
energy expert Hobart pash was involved
in the design
he says closed windows and good
insulation are key if you knock on the
wall you hear that there's no masonry
just behind the surface but a lot of
insulation about 30 centimeters thick
usually made of styrofoam then it's
coated with insulating stucco
the windows and patio doors have triple
glazing and there's a good ventilation
system that keeps the air circulating
doesn't pacify his eye nowadays it's
easy to build homes to passive house
standards off the rack so to speak
non-residential buildings are harder
there you have to take a closer look at
the use and come up with a tailor-made
solution it's more of a challenge for
everybody involved for example the local
kindergarten and an office building
still under construction sometimes
they'll be empty other times full the
ventilation heating and cooling system
has to cope with the fluctuations
further south in the Harvin's book
stands the world's first museum built to
these exacting standards you can feel
the air is really good here the
atmosphere is great people like to spend
time here the temperature doesn't vary
wildly as it would with a conventional
air-conditioning system
art lovers feel good here and curators
are fascinated by the innovative
technology I had my doubts because there
were no comparable buildings but in fact
it fulfills all the conditions we set to
keep our works of art in optimal
condition about 20,000 people a year
visit the museum they represent a
challenge for the climate control system
visitors are problematic because they
not only generate heat they also bring
in pollutants from outside and moisture
which isn't great for paintings so the
ventilation had to be up to dealing with
those challenges sensor send data to the
control unit which responds to the
changing conditions behind the scenes it
takes a lot of equipment to make it all
work passive house principles can be
deployed all over the world there's an
independent Research Institute in
Darmstadt devoted to developing the
passive house concept the implementation
of the principles has to match the
climatic conditions of each specific
location Africa is generally warmer than
Germany so you tend to need less thermal
insulation there and you can use double
rather than triple glazing
you can often meet passive house
standards thereby simpler means than in
Germany at the housing complex in
Heidelberg heating costs tend to be just
one tenth of what they would be in
normal homes and Pitka Beijing for one
says there's hardly any downside if I'm
cooking or I have guests there might be
eight of us sitting here at the table
we'll be eating or playing a game and
then sometimes it does get hot eight of
us are letting off heat there are two
options either you open the window or
you turn the ventilation system up
higher that speeds up the flow of air so
the warm air is distributed much faster
through the house one thing you have to
get used to is not to open the windows
all the time and in summer it's
important to keep sunlight off the
windows so the interior doesn't heat up
too much it's easier to keep a home cool
than to cool it down once it's hot